okay I'm not entirely sure if this is
live but if it is welcome this is Eric
Rosen I'm back for another live stream
on leech s and I was actually about to
hostess imal but then I realized that
when I do host ass I'm elated rating
which is very very low so I'm gonna play
a few standard games hopefully get my
rating at least above 2000 and I think I
just gained 84 points because my
opponent forgot to move or was just too
intimidated so that's nice over 1,700
now we'll see how many games it takes to
to break mm I think this is just 10
minutes s no increments and I've been
playing a lot of bullet chests so it's
gonna be weird to actually have some
time to think in it and kind of talk
through the moves with this line I I do
like taking the pawn on c5 because
there's very tricky move if he takes on
c5 with the bishop I have 94 and this
confuses a lot of people so we'll see
how he responds I've had a ton of bullet
games which have gone just like this
with with Bishop e7 96 and I'm instantly
getting the bishop pair and a very
annoying Queen on d6
so actually if we go back just to
explain for whoever's watching I can see
that there there is no one watching
right now is that true refreshing the
page
oh there's two people watching one of
them is me so for the one person out
there who's watching if you if you ever
got this position as black the best move
is Knight f6 I know if I can draw an
arrow but the idea would be if Knight
takes e5 Queen 85 check and then black
does give up the bishop pair but gets
very reasonable development and good
center with the two center pawns anyway
plays Queen e7 I'm gonna play Bishop f4
I really just idea is to reinforce d6
queenside castle next move and if I can
keep a piece on d6 whether it be a
bishop or a queen he's gonna have a very
hard time completing developments so at
this point I can kind of just sit back
and relax and see if there's any
comments in the chat
I don't think I'm actually watching live
okay there we go yeah so I'm the only
one watching right now what I'll
probably do is upload this to YouTube
just to get kind of a more consistent
stream of videos and then for whoever is
out there who enjoys my content they can
go back and watch this later so really
I'm talking to those who might be
watching this on YouTube at a later
point knight c6 I don't think really
does too much I'm just gonna Queens not
Castle maybe it would have been better
for him to play Knight f6 now he has
some idea of 94
so the first move that pops into mind is
just f3 I'm stopping 94 but then the
next question is kind of loud 94 and set
up some trap in some way or create some
counter-attack don't know if it's
possible 94 is kind of annoying move too
Queen take you 797 he's threatening d5
okay let's play f3 if he doesn't do
anything that I'm just gonna play like
efore and some sort of developing moves
like Bishop c4 92 and just really pose a
question to see what he's doing now he
might play e5 here which looks somewhat
reasonable actually maybe something I I
forgot about 95 also move
so if I play Bishop to g3 which is like
one of the more natural moves he has 93
which is very annoying hi he's 93 in a
lot of cases if I move my Bishop back
it might be that white doesn't have like
a huge advantage here I'm actually
leaning towards this Queen takee 7
Bishop d2 and then it's hold on to the
two bishops for later should maybe
consider dropped 85 ripped 85 taketake
Oh
let's fight positionally I'm not going
to take too many risks
I feel like that's a common mistake like
a lot of players would make they would
maybe try and over push and try and try
too hard to prove their advantage with a
move like rook take d5 but here I can be
relatively certain that white still has
a at least a small edge to bishops efore
coming with tempo the half-opened e-file
is also nice because the D pawn is
somewhat of a long-term weakness even
though it's not technically a backwards
pawn it's gonna have a hard time
advancing forward let's finish it before
it's weird I've moved my dark-squared
bishop just so many times but it is
being annoying for him in some regard I
wanted to play Bishop b5 but he has a 6
see how to develop
I would love to get a night on g6 but it
takes a ton of moves and the only way to
get there is via c4 or b5
okay I'll play Knight to e2 well I was
trying to do is like come up with some
ideal setup for whites and I was
envisioning like the knight coming to c3
and then eventually either Knight d5 or
Bishop e5 d5 is a little bit surprising
I thought opening the center should be
bad for its King but maybe not let's
play Knight c3 if he takes on e4 oh this
should be five and okay there should be
a lot of counter play it's based on
intuition
so I see there's one person watching if
you have any questions feel free cuz I
think there's a lot of downtime in these
uh these standard games
go ahead play Bishop b5 with tempo and
now I'm starting to calculate because
now there's some potential forcing lines
coming up
for example Bishop taking seven if he
takes on b5 I take on a six so that
one's a piece so this should take e7
king take you seven take on c64 takes c6
I'm just winning upon I think d5 jobs in
the end I should start playing a bit
quicker but this is a pretty low risk
way of playing just putting my pieces on
good squares waiting for my opponent to
give me something free and then it's a
matter of converting the technical Rock
ending
pretty sure I can prove this
I'm thoroughly working one check yeah
this is actually a good kind of
practical ending to show how to win
because sometimes it's not that obvious
like how white wins with just one extra
pawn when there's no no pass pawns in
this case it should be maybe a bit
easier than normal because I was gonna
say my rook can get to the seventh rank
but maybe that's not the case
yeah let's trade rooks okay so we'll go
with the strategy here of pushing on the
side where I have the majority which is
on the Queen side I don't think it was a
threat of rookie - let's start with c4
if Ricky - wrote d2 and the long-term
idea is just keep pushing the Queen side
pawns and this King is always cut off
this team can never enter the D file
which means that I should be able to
well now now after the rook trade it's
just very easily winning this is uh it's
actually a common mistake among a lot of
players they'll trade down to a King
pawn ending not realizing how easily
winning it is and the strategy here for
a white was the same as last time just
create pass pawn on the Queen side but
with no more rooks it's it's impossible
for black to create any sort of counter
play for
just a matter of closing down the
kingside
start with c5
and yeah for those who are watching on
twitch if you guys have any questions if
you have I know anything you want me to
to explain or answer in terms of of
anything chess really and they'd feel
free to ask I'm kind of just doing this
as a test for today and then if it works
out and I get some interest I might do
this on a more regular basis okay so the
I think the easiest way to win this
position is to stalemate him but not
actually stalemate him because he has
one move and then I'll promote with
meats rook okay
yeah so overall I think that was a
pretty smooth game I thought maybe I
should have a bigger advantage in the
opening I'm not entirely sure if there's
much else I can do differently Bishop f4
seemed most logical
hmm maybe I could have played efore
sooner before healer and then that
prevents this whole 95 idea and then
just got to be more space from the
earlier on but we go forward I think one
of the the biggest mistakes he made was
opening the center when his king and
also like his minor pieces they were all
kind of somewhat vulnerable
I gotta had a lot of pressure in this
position in the center and my pieces
were just better place for the center
opening up so yes with game it would
have been nice if he didn't trade rooks
to show like how how white wins
ascending that's done it's pretty simple
with black ties rookie rook to e1 I
would start marching marching pawns
eventually plays c5 and then just make
sure that his rook can't can't be too
annoying maybe put upon in h3 make sure
everything's defended so anyway play at
least one more game I see there's three
people watching two of which are not me
feel free comment in the chat I would
like to know like who you guys are where
you guys are from what your chest level
is my goal with this is to kind of cater
to whoever's watching so if there's a
strong players watching I'll speak it
may be a higher level but there's
beginners watching then I can certainly
explain at a more basic level - I've
gained 207 points by just playing
I just playing one game it's the first
game my opponent didn't didn't show up
I don't think I've ever played in the
classical tournament before so I was
just my third rated classical game it
seems like it's much slower pace than
these these bullet tournaments that I
usually play in I usually play Sicilian
but against weaker players I find that
it's easier to win quickly with a 45
especially when queen h5 is played now
the standard move here is knight c6 and
just knight c6 Bishop c4 g6 not getting
mated I'm gonna play a gambit Knight f6
allowing Queen to e5 but Ike I've seen
this once before and I'm pretty sure
black get some decent compensation I'm
not scared of Bishop h6 because I've at
least 98 let's play rookie AIDS
my goal is just to open the center I
play d5 and try and make use of my very
big leading developments
and I should note that if he plays the
e5 here I just take it
it's a five-night take e5 Queen's Aggie
five I would have had bishop before
check but maybe with c3 maybe his plan
is to play e5 let's see here so if I
play d5 he plays d5 I take he takes I
don't think there's any great
discoveries
I'm just kind of annoying
she was also threatening to play you
five
and if I play d5 e5 97 he was t4 and
maybe this uh this opening wasn't as
great as I thought it would be there is
an interesting move here Bishop to c5
because he can't play d4 right away and
then I'm threatening d5 now let's go for
this yeah it's in the position like this
this x-ray vision against the King is
really important and if I can open the
e-file before he castles it can be very
strong so for example if he just does
something normal like not a three here I
would play d5 and then after take for
example Knight take his Bishop would be
would would be a major target and the
only thing defending it would be the
King so let's go for d5 Wow d4 I really
want to sack more so efficient 84 pawn
to d4 1984
I could take 94 first
so Bishop lady for pawn to d4 Knight 84
threatening ic2 if he tries to the fence
eat to because it move like Queen c3 I
have a good feeling that Black has a lot
of compensation I'll go for this and
against a player like this I'm not too
scared taking a risk even if it doesn't
work out and I don't win right away I'll
have at least some some kind of
longer-term compensation maybe know
Nina's king is still stuck expecting
Queen c3 here after Queen c3 I'd
probably have a choice I could take on
an e fourth pawn I could play c5 I could
take on you to then take on e4 I think
it's really important to have maybe a
different sort of mindset in this
position rather than thinking about like
how to kill him I just have to figure
out how to prevent him from completing
development so after I move like Queen
c3 I would probably just take on e4 and
detaii for because then it's very
unclear how he finishes developing I
need any sort of his pieces Queen d3 I
think it's similar I'll go ahead and
take
I mean Queen D through I think was just
worse because now it comes with tempo
and probably the best move for him is
Queen c3 here okay so now question is
what do I want to do or maybe the more
important question is what does he want
to do and how do I stop it I really have
no idea what he wants to do maybe it
move like Knight b3 try and trade off
that night so I'm wondering if I can
create some threats and also improve the
position just ignore that for one moment
looking at e3 here III pawn to g3 rook
taking 3 it's kind of generating some
tactics I like it I think it took me
longer than usual to find this move
because I was thinking about prophylaxis
rather than just pure offense I've
accomplished my goal of opening the
e-file and he just I love this as a
blunder and maybe was the best try for
him because after King f2 Knight take
III King take III he still has a good
amount of material for the Queen and
it's still not trivial how I win some
part of me wants to play Knight g4 first
let's take the Queen though so it's a
really odd material imbalance it's this
is Queen and two pawns for rook bishop
in Knights but as king is on e3 the most
active piece I play c5 threatening Queen
d4 he plays might be three then I'd
probably develop the bishop or something
let's play c5 oh then he has Knight f3
and I have Knight g4 he's almost getting
Natan yeah
yeah so if he if he plays Knight f3
stopping Queen d4 I have not G for and
looks like a pretty nice mating net if
he plays Knight b3 I would probably play
like Bishop e6 or something
okay king of two
that's my queen d4 I'm gonna just go for
the kill if he plays whatever key move
he plays I'll probably play hoping for
King f1 to play 95 95 now he is 9 of 3
let's throw in another check he is g3
okay change of plans I should really
develop and that's the type of move I've
I play without even calculating because
I've realized that if I got a rook to e8
any time soon it should be very very
deadly now the line to calculate here it
would be 9 f3 and then figure out where
the Queen wants to move Knight G f-35
like Queen III does Knight c4 kind of
annoying
I see I have a comment which I'll read
after I make my next move let's just
play Queen d5 From Russia With Love from
Liliana Kay okay so I know you were
watching the the last stream - I like
chess but barely understand it and I'm
in so much pain because of its thanks
for your stream nice to look at the home
win them all
I should be right back
okay sorry about that
whops still my opponents move didn't
really waste any time so what happens
when the grandma calls I mean if this
were like a high-level or Grand Master
game it's still not entirely clear if
black is better
hmm I'll just throw in Queen d3
threatening mates I think he has to play
rook f2
so to move my bishop
hmm
yeah I think he's surviving here after a
king f1 he's gonna have to I'm gonna
have to move my Queen back he might
actually succeed in somehow finishing
developments let's play Queen C to keep
it a little bit weird
it might be that I'm just going or I'm
still trying to go for paralysis we're
just trying to be annoying enough where
he can't he can't figure out how to set
the rest of his development was it he's
very limited on squares here for most of
his pieces I'm looking at a move like
Knight c4 but that runs into wrote a key
to
Bishop c4 I was secretly hoping for this
but I didn't think it would actually
happened now it's just made next move
can free move between t1 and
unfortunately for the one person
watching which is probably a yarmulke
unless someone else tuned in this is
gonna be my last game and I'm gonna have
to go very soon but I will give a quick
recap if we go all the way back I played
a lot more ambitiously than normal and I
played probably in a bit more dubious
manner because my opponent was weaker
and I was I was simply trying to win
quickly and usually in order to do that
in chess sometimes you you have to play
moves which aren't objectively the best
and that's sort of what happened I
probably have the worst position here
but we got in a situation where it it
wasn't easy for white to find the right
kind of consolidating moves and he was a
little bit slow to develop and that's
Schieffer even at the very end of the
game he wasn't completed with
development and it did take this risk
but it was a fun game yeah this e3 move
was nice and this position was kind of
funny but I mean looking back on it I
don't know if I would I would be that
comfortable here against like a strong
player knowing that if white doesn't get
mated and and brings out the rest of the
pieces but could easily just be worse
here but okay thankfully I was playing
someone who was prone to pondering and
the game ended I think 25 moves can
still be considered a miniature so I
I'll leave it at that thanks for whoever
in the world was was watching at any
point during the stream I'll probably
end up uploading this to YouTube and
then just try to start advertising my
twitch channel a bit more anyway take
care I'll see you guys in the next next
video bye
[Music]